digamos que tengo una transformación y
que esta transformación t
pues es lineal entonces eso quiere decir
que al aplicarlo algún vector x esto lo
puedo escribir como una matriz a que es
bueno alguna matriz a aplicado a este
vector x muy bien entonces además de
detener esta transformación vamos a
suponer algo muy fuerte muy muy fuerte y
eso es que la forma reducida y
escalonada por renglones de nuestra
matriz a es decir al hacer todas esas
operaciones que que lo llevan a su forma
escalonada por renglón es ésta la matriz
que queda es la matriz identidad de
tamaño n entonces esto inmediatamente me
está diciendo que esta matriz no tiene
cualquier tamaño arbitrario sino que
tiene que ser cuadrada verdad porque el
tamaño de ésta debe ser exactamente
igual al tamaño de ésta entonces si ésta
es de n por n por definición de la
matriz identidad entonces esta matriz de
aquí también tiene que ser de tamaño n
por n entonces esto me está diciendo que
mi transformación
del espacio rn a rn muy bien entonces
vamos muy bien hasta ahí nada más
esta condición de aquí de que la forma
reducida y escalonada sea la identidad
esto solito me está diciendo mucho como
mencionamos aquí me está diciendo que la
matriz es de tama es cuadrada es de n
por n y que por lo tanto el espacio en
digamos los espacios desde el cual estoy
mapeando es decir el dominio es
exactamente el mismo que el contra
dominio verdad y la otra cosa que me
dice y que lo vimos en el último vídeo
es que la matriz y la que de hecho
perdón que la transformación es
invertible eso es algo muy fuerte que me
está diciendo entonces de aquí podemos
concluir que t es invertible
es invertible muy bien entonces vamos a
recordar qué es lo que significa que una
matriz que una transformación perdón sea
invertible ok entonces que que te sea
invertible significa que existe ok que
existe que era lo que existía puede ser
existía una transformación
que existe una transformación y que de
hecho la denota vamos como sea la menos
1 t inversa y está esta transformación
es tal que si la componemos digamos que
sea la menos 1 y la componemos con t
esto me da exactamente la identidad en
el contra dominio verdad es el
perdón en el dominio bueno el punto es
que como va de rn a rn es la identidad
en rn y ahora que si invertimos el orden
de t seguida de té a la menos uno esto
es lo mismo que la identidad también en
rn y nos estamos tomando r él es la
identidad en en el mismo porque va de rn
a rn entonces no hay no hay ningún
problema como como se ve esto como como
lo veríamos en un dibujo digamos que
aquí tengo mi espacio r n y aquí vuelvo
a tener ese mismo espacio
rn lo que me está diciendo es fíjate si
tú te tomas primero te ok si nos tomamos
t
te va de rn a este rn ok entonces al
tomarnos cualquier elemento aquí y le
aplicamos t
llegamos a algún punto en el contra
dominio verdad entonces si después le
aplicamos la inversa esto me está
diciendo que es exactamente la identidad
es decir que tenemos que regresar al
mismo punto de a la menos 1 entonces
esta composición al final resultó ser ir
a este rn y regresar al mismo punto pues
fue exactamente lo mismo que no haber
hecho nada es decir tener la identidad
verdad la identidad en ere n muy bien y
por supuesto entonces esta es la
identidad en el dominio ahora qué
hubiera pasado si por ejemplo me voy
primero con de este punto conté a la
menos 1 ok me voy primero por aquí y
después aplicó t después aplicó t y
regreso a este punto pues al haber
ocurrido eso no cambiamos nada llegamos
al mismo punto eso quiere decir que esta
composición no es otra cosa más que la
identidad
rn pero esté pensado de la identidad en
el co dominio muy bien muy bien entonces
ya sabemos que t es una transformación
lineal que satisface estas propiedades
con su transformación inversa pero
además por ser lineal pues tiene tiene
una matriz por la cual está definida y
demás la siguiente pregunta que es muy
inmediata es que una vez que sabemos que
t es lineal nos podemos preguntar si su
inversa es una transformación lineal es
decir será cierto
no me agradó será cierto que te a la
menos uno es una transformación
transformación ok si es una
transformación pero será cierto que es
lineal
será cierto que es una transformación
lineal y lo que sabemos es que para
hacer una transformación lineal se debe
cumplir dos cosas verdad que si nosotros
aplicamos una transformación a una suma
verdad nosotros sabemos que t es lineal
porque está definida por esta matriz
entonces te satisface que al aplicarlo a
una suma de vectores esto será igual a
la suma de las transformaciones verdad
esto es te de x + tdi y no sólo eso la
otra condición para que sea lineal es
que si nosotros aplicamos la
transformación a un escalamiento digamos
de este vector que no es otra cosa más
que multiplicarlo por un por un escalar
por un número real esto va a ser igual a
que si el real lo sacamos es decir re
escalar la transformación del vector ok
entonces estas dos condiciones son son
las que me permiten ver si una
transformación es lineal y son las dos
condiciones que tenemos que ver que se
cumplan para la transformación inversa
entonces vamos a vamos a ir explorando
vamos a experimentar un poquito por
ejemplo qué pasaría si yo aplico té
seguida de té a la menos uno ok si yo se
lo aplicó a una suma ok vamos a vamos a
ver qué pasa en principio está compuesta
con té a la menos uno pues es la
transformación identidad entonces como
esto es la transformación identidad la
transformación identidad sabemos que no
le hace nada verdad a lo que le estemos
aplicando esta identidad no le hace nada
además ve entonces esto de aquí pues
simplemente va a ser más ve y eso es
porque esta es la transformación
identidad en la que no le hacen nada a
este a este sujeto que estamos
aplicándole la transformación pero
también podemos pensar que es aplicarle
la identidad a verdad pues si la
identidad pues esa pero podemos
reescribir la identidad de esta forma es
decir podemos pensar que esto este
seguida de té a la menos 1 que esto es
la identidad aplicado a muy bien esto es
la identidad aplicada y también podemos
pensarlo para b
verdad te ve este seguida de té a la
menos uno aplicado a ver e insisto esto
es cierto porque pues esto es la
identidad y la identidad aplicado ave es
ve muy bien lo mismo pasa con este de a
carrillo entonces esta suma de hecho
de hecho la podemos escribir así es
igual a esta suma muy bien entonces
déjenme déjenme ir reescribiendo todo
esto la lo que llegamos es que y de
hecho voy a cambiar un poquito la
anotación porque quizás y bueno yo no sé
cuál es la la forma en que el proceso
mejor tu cerebro esto para mí me
funciona más escribirlo de la siguiente
forma esto este aplicado ate a la menos
uno de a más b
muy bien también esta es otra forma de
escribir las composiciones entonces esto
aquí va a ser igual a t aplicado a quien
sea la menos uno de nuestro vector más t
aplicado a la menos uno de nuestro
vector b eso es lo que obtuvimos justo
en esta línea no estoy haciendo nada
nuevo sin embargo ahora lo que yo puedo
hacer es lo siguiente vamos a utilizar
que te cumple esta propiedad por ser
lineal t es lineal eso quiere decir que
te aplicado a una suma es igual a la
suma de que si aplicamos t a cada uno de
los elementos nosotros podemos ir ahora
de esto a la izquierda porque tenemos t
aplicado a dos vectores digamos este
sería el que juega el papel de x y este
sería el que juegue el papel debe
entonces por esta propiedad de aquí lo
que vamos a tener es que esto es igual a
t aplicado a la suma de estos dos es
decir ate a la menos 1
más que a la menos uno aplicado a b
muy bien entonces déjenme dejen a
reescribir todo esto solo para que no
carguemos con cosas innecesarias a lo
que llegamos es que te aplicado de este
lado te aplicado a tela - uno de hamás
ve
al menos uno más debe ser igual a lo que
tenemos de este lado t aplicado a tela
menos uno en a más de al menos 16 y
recuerdo que que esto salió por esta
propiedad de la linealidad de t verdad
aquí teníamos una suma de dos cosas a
las cuales le estamos aplicando t pues
eso es aplicar t a la suma de esas dos
cosas verdad es lo que está diciendo
aquí muy bien entonces si ya tenemos
esta expresión si ya tenemos esta
expresión podemos sacar la inversa de
estas dos podemos decir bueno qué pasa
si le aplicamos la inversa si aplicamos
la inversa de este elemento como es el
mismo es lo mismo que aplicarle la
inversa a este de la derecha lo que
estoy diciendo es que si aplicamos la
inversa a esto que está aquí del lado
izquierdo es lo mismo que aplicar la
inversa a esto que está del lado derecho
muy bien simplemente lo que hice fue
aplicar la inversa de ambos lados sin
embargo qué es lo que pasa aquí ya lo
que tenemos es
que tenemos de ala -1 compuesta con té
aplicado en este elemento verdad si yo
me tomo esto de aquí esto de aquí lo
podemos expresar como sea la menos 1
compuesto con té y a quien se lo estamos
aplicando a este a este otro de aquí
este otro de aquí entonces esto lo
estamos aplicando ate a la menos 1 de
además ve muy bien y esto a quien va a
ser igual nuevamente esto esto lo
podemos escribir como una composición
esto este a la menos 1 compuesto con té
muy bien
al menos uno compuesto con té de hecho
déjenme seguir usando los mismos colores
de esta forma vamos a ponerlo así esto
esté a la menos 1 seguida de té ok
es esta composición y a quien se lo
aplicamos pues se lo aplicamos
justamente a esto que está aquí adentro
se lo aplicamos hacia la menos 1 de a
más de a la menos uno debe muy bien y ya
estamos muy muy cerca de demostrar lo
que queremos llegar porque esta
composición no es otra cosa más que la
transformación identidad
en otro color esto es la identidad en rn
y esto también es de identidad en rn
entonces si esas dos son la identidad es
como hacerle nada verdad la identidad a
esto pues es simplemente esto así que lo
que tenemos del lado izquierdo es la
transformación inversa aplicada a amas
ve ok es igual y esto es la identidad
simplemente es lo que me queda aquí del
lado de este lado que es de ala menos
uno aplicado a más de a la menos uno
aplicado a ver y ya tenemos la primera
condición ya tenemos la primera
condición para que sea lineal sería es
exactamente esta pero para la función
inversa así que ya tenemos la primera
condición para que sea lineal
vamos a experimentar ahora con la otra
condición vamos a ver si podemos llegar
a algo
vamos a usar digamos la misma técnica
vamos a ver qué pasa con t compuesta
contra la menos 1 al aplicarlo a nuestro
a un múltiplo del vector a que la idea
de llegar a que está a la condición
digamos de t esta condición que tenemos
aquí pero párate a la menos 1 no hay que
perder de vista es entonces esto como es
la identidad simplemente es lo que
tenemos aquí esto es la identidad
aplicado a algo pues es algo
entonces esto es de veces
muy bien pero a nuevamente lo podemos
reescribir como la identidad por a no
sea esto es seis veces la identidad que
por ejemplo lo podemos escribir como t
compuesta con té a la menos uno porque
esto es la identidad y eso lo sabemos de
de acá arriba verdad esto
eso sí lo sabemos aplicado a entonces
esto fue como no haberle hecho nada sólo
escribirlo como la identidad por muy
bien y en realidad eso eso está de hecho
por qué porque si es claro que te que
sea la menos uno pero más bien que a es
igual a ti compuesta contra la menos uno
de a verdad porque esto es la identidad
y la identidad no le hace nada a los
vectores muy bien entonces qué es lo que
tenemos vamos a reescribir mejor los
reescribimos de esta forma esto este
aplicado ate a la menos uno aplicado
hace por a verdad y esto es igual a
quien del lado derecho que me queda que
me queda esto s
que multiplica te aplicado acteal a
menos uno vea muy bien entonces lo que
podemos hacer aquí es usar que t es
lineal y como es lineal las constantes
que están afuera las meten muy bien
entonces esta constante entra esta
constante entra vamos a ponerlo con este
color y esto sería t y la constante
entrada multiplicándose por t a la menos
uno de a muy bien entonces déjenme
déjenme reescribir esto simplemente
quitando este paso intermedio
entonces lo que tenemos es
aplicado ate a la menos uno de sepor a
es igual a t por bueno aplicado hace
corte a la menos uno de a y supongo que
ya estás viendo muy bien cuál es el
siguiente paso porque esto es muy
similar a lo que obtuvimos en el en el
caso anterior lo que podemos hacer es de
ambos lados aplicar la transformación
inversa aplicamos la transformación
inversa de ambos lados y que es lo que
me queda
qué es lo que me queda de este lado me
queda tela -1 compuesta con te verdad es
justo esto de aquí aplicado a lo que
tenga aquí que esté a la menos uno
aplicado hace por a
muy bien y del lado de perdón derecho
que es lo que me queda me queda de al
menos 1
compuesto con té
aplicado a lo que me queda que es se
porte a la menos uno aplicado a
ok ahí está entonces justo todo el
detalle de por qué hice esto es porque
esto es la identidad es la identidad en
rn y esto también es la identidad en rn
entonces la identidad no le hace nada a
los vectores a los cuales le está
aplicando entonces si no les hace nada
solo me quedan estos dos de aquí bien
entonces lo que me queda es que te ala
menos uno aplicado a c por a es igual a
c veces de a la menos 1 por a y justo de
esta era la segunda condición de las
transformaciones para hacer lineales ok
entonces en este caso usamos que que t
era lineal para demostrar que si las las
constantes digamos las acá las
transformaciones inversas y también
usamos que t lineal para demostrar esta
propiedad de que la transformación
inversa aplica una suma es la suma de
las transformadas inversas muy bien
entonces en efecto usamos la linealidad
de t para demostrar a ambos casos y
concluimos entonces que la inversa en
línea
ahora sabemos que la transformación si
es lineal si es lineal t invertible
entonces la inversa también es lineal
vamos a escribir eso
si te es una transformación lineal
transformación lineal pero pues además
queremos que sea invertible verdad es
invertible
en invertible entonces qué es lo que
ocurre entonces la inversa sabemos que
existe porque es invertible también
resultó ser línea también es una
transformación lineal
transformación
lineal
muy bien entonces parece algo muy
sencillo digo uno a lo mejor podría
intuir que si tienes una transformación
lineal la inversa debería ser lineal
parece algo muy sencillo pero en
realidad es algo muy muy grande y use un
resultado muy fuerte porque que quiere
decir que sea lineal esto implica que te
ala -1 aplicado un vector pues como
todas las transformaciones lineales y
que ya hemos visto es aplicarle o más
bien multiplicar al vector por una
matriz que déjenme poner aquí algo así
como la inversa de a ok no hemos
definido que es la inversa de una matriz
pero sabemos que existe una matriz que
define a esta transformación que es la
inversa da más por cosas que ya veremos
le pongo a la menos 1 la inversa de a ok
entonces qué es lo que sabemos
sabemos que t
seguida de la menos 1 seguida de t es la
identidad
en rn muy bien la identidad en rn pero
además también sabemos que te de x te
aplicado a equis pues es una matriz a
por nuestro vector x entonces si
nosotros lo aplicamos esto algún vector
particular es decir si tenemos t a la
menos 1 compuesta con t y que multiplica
a x
esto primero se ha aplicado a x por lo
que tenemos aquí es la matriz a que
multiplica x y luego aplicamos t a la
menos 1 de x que es aplicarle que es
multiplicar por la matriz a la menos 1 y
justamente por aquí es de donde sale la
necesidad de multiplicar matrices
entonces además sabemos si sabemos que
esto es la identidad entonces esto es lo
mismo esto es lo mismo
y ponerlo así esto es la identidad en rn
aplicado a nuestro vector x pero la
identidad en rn por ser lineal también
sabemos que la matriz que la define la
matriz identidad de tamaño n verdad
aunque ya que no van no van los
paréntesis aquí simplemente es la matriz
que multiplica este vector entonces ya
para concluir me dice que esta matriz
esta multiplicación de dos matrices debe
ser esta matriz de acá es decir que a la
menos uno que multiplica debe ser la
matriz identidad de tamaño n muy bien y
por otro lado que es lo que sabemos
también que está compuesta contra la
menos 1 también es la identidad
en rn entonces de la misma forma como
procedemos podemos vemos podemos ver que
si aplicamos que si aplicamos la inversa
de a ok y después le aplicamos a a
nuestro vector x esto va a ser lo mismo
que la matriz identidad de tamaño n del
vector x entonces nos dice algo muy
fuerte que a multiplicada por al menos 1
también es la matriz identidad y eso es
muy bonito porque sabemos que el
producto de matrices no siempre conmuta
no siempre podemos intercambiar el orden
y aquí me está diciendo qué
si podemos intercambiar el orden con sus
matrices inversas y más aún que la que
el producto en ambos casos me debe dar
la matriz identidad ok entonces ahora
que ya hemos llegado tan lejos el
siguiente paso es ver cómo construyen la
matriz inversa digo sabemos que sabemos
que estas cosas existen las
transformaciones inversas sabemos que la
inversa es una transformación lineal y
que por lo tanto la define una matriz es
decir esta matriz existe la matriz que
le llamamos ingenuamente a la menos uno
y vimos esta propiedad de que al
multiplicar estas matrices obtienes la
matriz identidad así que el siguiente
paso es descubrir la forma de obtener
quién es este sujeto